*voix off* " Le conflit le plus meurtrier du XXème siècle fait rage."
" Alors que les nations du monde entier sont sur le point de s'embraser,-- "
" Un homme va changer à jamais le cours de l'histoire. "
OK !
*rire*
OK c'est partis.
Alors là aujourd'hui on est trés hypé parce qu'un jeu sur la seconde guerre mondiale,--
en réalité virtuelle, en FRANCE !!
Putain ça cumule tous les facteurs stylé.
Ah OK plein de mission.
Eh bah on va les faires dans l'ordre !
"Start game" première misions
OOH !
Jvais sauté en parachute mon gars !
Jvais sauté en parachute
"Stand here"
Ok j'attend
10 secondes
Dans 10 secondes mec j'dois sauté !
C'EST TROP BIEN !!
Les Gars ! Est-ce que vous êtes pre...
MON CHAPEAU !!
NAN !
FAUT PAS QUI S'ENVOLE !
"Stand behind the line"
OK  jsuis derrière, jsuis derrière !
Jsuis prêt
"Step off the plane"
C'EST PARTIS
WOOAAAHAAH =D
C'EST TROP BIEN MEC !!!
ON ARRIVE !
MON CHAPEAU P*TAIN, j'ai faillis le faire tombé bordel
Faudrais pas qu'il tombe sur la tête d'un allemand.
Ohlala !
Attend mais on a...
MAIS P*TAIN mon chapeau *rires*
WOOOHOOOO !!!!
*inspiration chelou*
On est en pleine chute mon gars !
Oooooh
C'est bon. OK on est en train d'atterir
Wooheuh
Aaah !!
On a atteris dans une maison
Ooooh !
"Squeeze grip button to pick up weapon"
Oooh on va sniper ?!
Alors "pull bolt back with other hand to reload (trigger)."
Ah OK.
Jrecharge.
Et là je tire.
Oh mon dieu !
Nan nan, il m'a vu, IL ARRIVE, IL ARRIVE, IL ARRIVE !!!
M*rde faut que j'recharge.
P*UTAIN jsuis un des pires sniper d'Europe quoi !
Pourquoi ils m'ont envoyé moi dans le passé sans déconner ?
ON L'A EU !!!! :D
Oooooh *jouissement*
Y a un deuxième, y a un deuxième.
Ah il est là.
*Tirs répétitifs*
P*tain attend j'suis bigleux, il m'faut des lunettes.
Attend mais il va s'ramener !
Attend no scope
OH ! OHOH !
No scope in the, in the couilles.
Aller pourquoi viser quand on peut juste faire... au jugé
Ooh !
*rire*
Mec jsuis meilleur sans viser !
Oh mon dieu !
En plein mouvement on l'a eu ce con !
*tirs*
Alleeerrrr !!
*encore des tirs*
Alleeeer !
Suivant !
Et t'as vu je tiens pas du tout comme un sniper.
Oh ! C'est beau !
Encore !
Mais arrêter d'arriver un moment !
Normalement j'ai tué toute l'armée déjà ?!
Tieeeeent !
Aaah ! Suivant ! Suivant, suivant, suivant !
Appelez moi "the French sniper"
Tieeeens
Suivant !
*tirs*
Okééééé !
YOLO !
*rire*
*tirs*
NAN !
P*tain mais mec !
C'est bon j'ai compris le mécanisme.
Encore un, encore un.
OHLALALALAAAH !!!
Mais qui peut le stopper ? Il vient de loin il s'appelle Lafouine !
Ah !
Ah mes vertèbres !
C'est fini ?
On a gagné la guerre tu penses Clément ?
Bon ben voilà.
Aller !
Hitler soit pas dég.
C'est faux.
*rire*
Je récupère mes mains et on fait la deuxième mission !
Alors ?
On est où là ?
C'est quoi ce délire ?
D'accord y a des pierres.
Faut que j'lances des cailloux, faut vraiment que... ?
Oh y a de l'allemand là mec.
Elle est où... , il est où mon sniper ?
Faut que j'lance des pierres ?!
Ah !
Ca marche pas dutout
Oh y a la tour Eifel !
Génial.
*Bruits d'allemand qui s'approchent*
Oh faut que je m'accroupisse.
Oh y a des gens qui arrivent ?!
Mais non !
On va prendre deux pierres, ...au cas ou.
Oh mon dieu !
HOP LAAAA !!!
Dans ton cul !
*rire*
Tient j'vais te réanimer, viens là !
J'peux pas le déga...
*rire*
Ah, Oh !!!
*SQUEEZIE en PLS*
C'est quoi ?
C'est le capteur.
*grosse tristesse :'(*
Mais nan ?
NAAAAAAN !!!
*rires*
Et commment voulez vous que je sauve la France si vous m'aidez pas ?
Ah duocup ça a décapité le...
*rires*
J'croyais c'était un collabo le capteur, mais pas dutout !
Merci !
OK on arrête les conneries fils de p*te !
Aller on y va, c'est partit.
J'suis caché !
Sois pas dég !
Aller dans les burnes mon pote.
ALORS vous allez faire quoi !!!
Woooh !!
Oh p*tain !
Eh il va arriver, il va arriver !
BLARH !
*rire*
Mon gars comment on l'a défoncé !
Retourne trier les palettes Intermarché connard !
La décapitation de vos hommes--
Voilà ce qui vous attend !
Ta gueule, voilà merci.
Mais sinon j'attend juste là enfait.
Sinon on fait les snipers-campeurs.
*rire*
Ça vous plait ce gameplay ou pas ?
Oh !
Perdu !
*rire*
Oh !
Perdu !
Pourquoi viser de loin ?
Quand tu peux juste camper comme ça.
C'est vrai ou pas ?
Hop là ça dégage !
Aller on attend, suivant !
Hitler viens là !
Ça dégage.
Oh merde !
Mauvaise idée, mauvaise idée !
*crie aiguë*
Hop là !
Nan !
Mais j'suis là !
Hop làààààà !!!
Qu'est-ce tu vas faaaaaaire !!!
Je t'ai--
tu--
--é !!!
Tiens, tiens ! Enc*lé !
Nan mais les mecs ils sont vraiments nuls quoi !
Il m'voit jsuis là d'vant eux--
Alors tu meurs ? Tiens pan !
Oh y a un char.
Clément ?!
Faut faire quoi quand y a un char ?
Tiens !
Va t'en !
C'est mon tertaire ici.
Tu peux pas test.
Pouce ! On arrête la guerre !
C'est l'heure du gouté !
*sirène d'alarme*
Oh !
C'est les alliés !
C'EST LES ALLIES !!!
Ouais les gars !!!
Merci les gars de nous venir en aide !!!
Merci.
*Sauvetage de Superman*
Attend y a carrément Superman qui est venu me chercher ?!
BON !
" For the fatherland "
Ok, c'est partis j'suis prêt.
Oh ! C'est horrible ce qu'on fait !
Là j'suis allemand.
J'suis totalement allemand.
J'suis uuuuuun... j'suis uuun ennemi.
Voilà on va pas s'mentir.
Ok elle a des munitions infinies et pas d'rechargement.
Tu sais ce que ça veut dire ?
Ça veut dire qu'on va passer un bon moment.
*tirs*
:3
Dés qu'ils avaient de l'eau sous la ceinture les américains--
T'avais pas le droit de leur tirer dessus.
Voilà c'était une règle.
Euuuuh...
Et nous finalement on s'en bas un peu les couilles là.
On respecte aucune règle mon gars !
Mais c'est super dur mec--
euuuh de de viser.
Tu sais quoi ?!
Aller technique du moulinet !
J'avais vu plusieurs personnes faire ça pendant la 2nde guerre mondiale.
C'est juste tu moulines.
Tu moulines !
Et y a forcément des gens qui se prendront des balles.
J'suis le pire allemand du monde.
Ah !
Oh m*rde !
Ah merde, merde, merde !
" To eject magazine press touch pad "
Mais attend le mec !
Pendant que je me fait tirer dessus il m'explique comment recharger quoi.
Bon.
C'est un échec :(
Ah d'accord ok--
En fait tu tires, tu recharges--
Y a un chargeur qui apparaît en bas--
Et tu mets l'arme dessus et tu peux re-tirer
OKéééééé !
Donc tu vois la règle de l'eau qu'on a dit juste avant, on va bien la respectée.
C'EST FAUX !!!
*crie*
*sifflement*
Ça va les gars ça se passe ?
Moi ça va.
*rire*
Le mec dans l'abus.
Ca va arriver dans pas longtemps.
T'sais quoi ?!
J'propose une alternative mec--
On campe là.
On peut s'poser tu voit, contre le muret.
Et on attend.
Franchement on s'fatiguera moins.
Oh !
Mais nan, mais nan !
NAN !
P*tain.
Ah ça commence à arriver !
Ok headshot.
On recharge, on attend.
Oh memememem*rde !
EH RECHARCHE !!!
OH MEC ILS SONT TELLEMENT NOMBREUX !!!
*rire*
Y avait tous les mecs devant p*tain.
Bon, bon, bon.
En fait c'est impossible de viser parce'que--
Pourquoi j'fais ça ?
Déjà parce que euuuuh
J'la tiens, j'peux la tenir à distance.
C'est totalement cheaté hein.
Professeur Xavier, bonjour c'est moi.
Et ensuite parce que quand j'regarde dans le viseur--
Je suis éblouis par les flash.
Je vois rien bordel.
Wohwohwoh !!!
Eh j'prend cher de ouf lààà.
Eh mais ils font quoi mes potes ils m'aident ou quoi ?! P*TAIN !
AH OK !
Nan, j'suis caché, j'suis caché, j'suis caché.
Ok c'est bon j'l'ai eus
M*RDE ! J'ai laché l'gun !
MAIS NAN !
MAIS NAN !!! D:
Il est où ? Il est où ?
J'AI PLUS D'GUN !!!!
NAN !
ATTEND ! POUCE !
Arréteuuuuh
*Squeezie est déter'*
Ca va chier mou !
*Musique épique*
J'suis foutu !
NAN !!!
NAN !
VOUS GAGNEREZ PAS LA GUERRE !!!
UN CONTRE TOUS !
AAAAH !!!!!
MAIS RECHARGE !!!
P*TAIN !!!
*Musique triste*
*Squeezie pleure :'(*
J'reviens du passé Clément tu sais ce qui s'est passé ?
J'ai baisé ta mère.
J'suis ton père Clément.
J'suis ton père :'(
Fiston viens là, viens là.
C'est pas grave.
Ca m'fait plaisir d't'voir.
Bon ben voilà c'que c'est d'envoyer le plus grand des cons dans l'passé pour sauver--
Les alliés
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu.
On s'retrouve trés vite prochaine, hein.
Moi j'retourne dans l'passé pour, euuuh faire foirer encore plus de guerre.
Ne soyez pas étonné--
Si dans vos livres d'histoire--
Tout d'un coup y a marqué qu'on a perdu toute les guerres--
J'en suis le responsable.
A trés vite !
C'était le pire soldat de l'univers !
*Musique d'outro*